eine riesige anlage am ende der welt
da wollte niemand
kam wahrscheinlich nie mehr zurück
[Musik]
ein verlassener außenposten in
arktischer kälte
man steckte dort mehr arbeitskraft und
kapital rein als eigentlich sinn gemacht
hätte
[Applaus]
die überreste eines monumentalen
bauwerks in riskanter lager
kommt es ständig dem urgewalt des meeres
ausgesetzt
und das größenwahnsinnige projekt eines
brutalen regimes
warum sollte jemand so viel zement mit
[Musik]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden die anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht
doch wer waren ihre erbauer wie wurden
sie errichtet und warum wurden sie
verlassen
[Musik]
auf der norwegischen inselgruppe
spitzbergen am rand des nordpolarmeeres
liegt eine seltsame siedlung am fuße
eines bergs
so etwas dort zu finden ist unglaublich
alles wirkt erstaunlich gut in schuss
sehr solide gebaut aber was einen
wirklich um haut ist dieser
pyramidenförmige berg er verleiht der
ganzen szenerie fast etwas mystisches
die landschaft ist rau und zugleich
atemberaubend schön
nächste siedlung ist meilenweit entfernt
und die umweltbedingungen sind extrem
hart
ist ziemlich lebensfeindlich
abgeschnitten vom rest der welt
dauerfrost und langen dunklen winter
die unwirtliche umgebung würde die
meisten menschen wohl abschrecken
die stadt im nirgendwo war allerdings
keine normale wohnsiedlung
[Musik]
mut dieser ort wurde nicht rein
funktional gestalteten alles hier wird
großzügig und kostspielig
es wurde entworfen gebaut und dekoriert
das piano wartete darauf gespielt zu
werden alles was noch fehlte waren die
menschen
warum baut man so eine vorzeigestadt am
ende der welt und warum steht sie heute
nahezu verlassen in der landschaft
die inselgruppe spitzbergen gehört seit
rund 100 jahren zu norwegen
doch bei genauerem hinsehen wird schnell
klar dass hier einst die sowjets das
sagen hatten
wohin man auch schaut alles atmet den
geist der ehemaligen sowjetunion
die architektur die schilder und
natürlich die linien büßte auf dem platz
im zentrum der stadt
schon erstaunlich dass lenin strenger
blick noch immer auf der stadt liegt
ob die berliner mauer nie gefallen wäre
die siedlung ist nach dem markanten berg
benannt der hinter ihr auftrag pyramiden
[Musik]
während ihrer blütezeit lebten hier mehr
als 1000 menschen
heute kümmern sich nur noch ein paar
freiwillige wie galina nazarenko um die
anlage
doch ganz allein sind sie hier nicht
manche finden es pizza rein andere
gruselig und wieder andere sind einfach
neugierig
neben einigen touristen und steinen
gefährliche besucher auf vier beinen
durch die verlassene stadt
die eisbären sind zu einer bedrohung
geworden heute mehr als früher weil es
so ruhig in der stadt ist verlieren die
bären die scheu
[Musik]
was hat die menschen einst in dieser
einöde gelockt
der grund dafür liegt tief unter der
frostigen erde
kohle
mehrere länder hatten deswegen ein auge
auf die inseln geworfen die meisten
kamen zu dem schluss dass sich der
aufwand nicht lohnen würde doch diese
sahen das anders
in einer so unwirtlichen gegend ist es
hart zu überleben geschweige denn der
anbau zu betreiben wie könnte da so ein
unternehmen profitabel sein
1927 wird die udssr die schürfrechte und
pumpt jahrzehntelang geld in die
siedlung
vor allem während des kalten kriegs
[Musik]
der gehobene standard der anlage lässt
vermuten dass es hier nicht nur um
bergbau ging
die stadtplaner konzentrierten sich
nicht nur auf die grundbedürfnisse
hier war ein komfort im spiel der darauf
hindeutet dass es noch ganz andere
gründe gab dort präsent zu sein
sie sorgt nicht nur für
bergbauausrüstung und unterkünfte
[Musik]
erstklassige wohnungen für alle
das leben in dieser bergarbeiterstadt am
ende der welt zwar komfortabler als in
der sowjetunion
es gab viele freizeitangebote ein
schwimmbad und ein kulturzentrum mit
sportplatz
das war toll für die bewohner
die bergarbeitersiedlung liegt mehr als
1000 kilometer von russland entfernt
aber sie ist damals wesentlich besser
ausgestattet als jede minenstadt hinter
dem eisernen vorhang
denn die kurve ist wohl nicht das
einzige worauf die sowjets es hier
abgesehen haben
manche glauben dass es dort niemals
genug kohle gar um eine florierende
stadt zu unterhalten eigentlich ging es
den sowjets darum einen aussenposten im
westen zu haben
während des ost-west-konflikts sucht die
sowjetregierung nach mitteln und wegen
zugang zum westen zu bekommen
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
er herrscht ein tiefes misstrauen
zwischen der sowjetunion und den usa
die supermächte konkurrieren um
politischen und wirtschaftlichen
einfluss ein massives wettrüsten beginnt
wer es schafft geografisch interessante
regionen wie spitzbergen zu
kontrollieren könnte dort spionage
posthum oder raketenabschuss basenbau
beiden seiten ist klar wenn es zu einem
atomkrieg käme hätte das verheerende
folgen für die ganze welt
im kalten krieg geht es deshalb vor
allem darum politische macht in
schlüsselregionen zu erlangen
demokraten und kommunisten wollen der
welt beweisen dass ihr system das
richtige ist und da kommt spitzbergen
ins spiel
das war sie noch mit ihnen es ging um
propaganda an ob die westliche welt
sollte sehen wie toll der kommunismus
funktioniert
die sache jetzt bauten eine
vorzeigestadt auf norwegischem gebiet wo
jeder im westen sie sehen konnte
ganz so als würden sie das beste was ihr
system zu bieten hatte fenster stellen
mit viel geld und unterstützung wird
pyramiden zum leuchtenden beispiel des
kommunismus aufgemotzt doch als der
eiserne vorhang fällt wird die
traumstadt von der bitteren realität
eingeholt
[Musik]
es ließ sich nicht länger schönreden man
die kohle zu kommen muskelmann immer
tiefer graben und das lohnte sich nicht
mehr
mit termine geht es bergab
eine katastrophe gibt der siedlung
wenige jahre später den rest
[Applaus]
[Musik]
1996 vor dem glück der ein flugzeug aus
moskau auf tragische weise beim anflug
auf die insel
141 menschen kommen bei dem unglück ums
leben
ein schlag von dem sich die gemeinde nie
wieder erholt hat
am 31 märz
1998 wird zum letzten mal kohle
gefördert
um die letzten einwohner verlassen die
stadt für immer
mit dem skiführer mieden zeigt dass man
noch so viel geld in ein projekt punkten
kann bestehen wenn es sich nicht selbst
trägt ist es letztlich zum scheitern
verurteilt
[Musik]
an der westküste der usa im schatten der
golden gate bridge liegt eine felsige
bucht übersät von ruinen
auf den ersten blick ist es schwer zu
sagen wie alt sie sind
wenn sie am mittelmeer legen könnte man
meinen sie stammen aus der zeit der
alten römer
[Musik]
faszinierender ort zunächst sieht man
nur ein paar verwitterte betonfundamente
aber je näher man hinschaut desto mehr
erkennt man
offensichtlich sollte sich die
konstruktion perfekt in die landschaft
einfügen aber warum
die trümmer erstrecken sich weit über
die klippen
unter den wellen die gegen die felsen
schlagen kann man mehrere becken erahnen
[Musik]
es hieß dass es nicht bloß ein kleiner
pool das gelände umfasst rund 1000
quadratmeter
man fragt sich ob das ganze mit der
schiffer zu tun hat vielleicht hoffen
dass eine fischfarm oder ein aquarium
[Musik]
zu welchem zweck wurde die anlage gebaut
und warum gerade hier am rand des ozeans
natürlich bewusst gewählt dass mehr
spielte bei dieser konstruktion offenbar
eine wichtige rolle aber wenn man so nah
an der küste baut es gibt es immer
probleme
die anlage am strand ist der vollen
wucht des pazifiks ausgesetzt aber das
soll nicht das einzige problem bleiben
vor rund 100 jahren wimmelt es hier von
ausflüglern aus dem nahen san francisco
[Musik]
damals bot die stadt wie verrückt und
ihre bewohner haben genug geld um es zum
vergnügen auszugeben
der deutsche einwanderer adolphs u draw
wittert eine chance
1881 kauf der reiche geschäftsmann die
bucht namens light kurs
[Musik]
die pazifik-küste bei san francisco ist
sehr felsig mit hohen wellen oktober
aufgefallen dass es hier viele gezeigte
puls die gischt sie schlägt auf die
felsen und fließt wieder ab das brachte
ihn auf eine idee man könnte aus diesen
natürlichen becken doch einen großen
pool machen und ihn als aquarium nutzen
zunächst lässt so ein sammelbecken
errichten
dem westlichsten punkt von san francisco
fing alles an
die arbeiter sprengten die spitze der
klipper
dass die wellen auf
durch einen versteckten tunnel fliesst
das meerwasser in ein gewaltiges becken
in den meerestiere gehalten werden so
können besucher diese vom land aus
bestaunen
[Musik]
eine derartige hightech anlage am rand
der klippen zu bauen ist eine mammut
aufgabe
die arbeitsbedingungen waren extrem
gefährlich die arbeiter können nur bei
apple bauen
und die kraft der elemente ist nicht die
einzige gefahr
eines nachts spülen die wellen etwas
anders die ganze anlage und supervision
auf einen schlag vernichten könnte
wir befinden uns hier innerhalb des
ursprünglichen aquariums
dieser teil hier wurde zerstört als ein
mit dynamit beladener segler da drüben
schiffbruch erlitt und mit einer
gewaltigen explosion in die luft flog
ein wrackteil krachte durch diese wand
ins aquarium
die anlage es damals noch mitten im bau
das projekt droht zu tun um die ohren zu
fliegen
auch der schmiedet nun sogar noch
größere pläne
lernt daraus und entwickelte ein system
das die kraft der gezeiten nutzte um
weiter im inland gelegenen puls zu
fühlen das eröffnet ganz neue
möglichkeiten
jede seit er wollte mehr an dem die
leute schwimmen können
will etwas großes erschaffen das die
welt so noch nicht gesehen hat
das war ziemlich cool so selbst nannte
es anspruchsvoll ihm schwebt eine
schwimmhalle vor schweiß vom meerwasser
und umgeben von einem glasdach
dies sind die überreste der
ihr erbauer träumt von einer bade
kathedrale direkt am strand umhüllt von
mehr als 9000 quadratmetern glas
neben mehreren meerwasserbecken soll es
500 umkleidekabinen 7 rutschen und ein
großes treffen ausgeben
aber lässt sich dieser ehrgeizige plan
überhaupt in die tat umsetzen
so eine konstruktion muss großen und
kleinen dellen standhalten je nachdem
was der ozean gerade zu bieten hat
ein zusammenspiel von kunst und natur
wer sich da wohl am ende durch
ein bauprojekt am strand wird ein hohes
risiko
um es zu realisieren sind besondere
schutzmaßnahmen nötig
zu true musste immer wieder zu sehen wie
die pools von strom fluten weggespült
wurde
erst als die arbeiter eine drei meter
dicke und fast 90 meter langen
betonmauer hochziehen kann der rest der
anlage fertiggestellt werden
das bad hatte neben einem großen becken
fünf kleinere puls jeder hatte eine
andere wassertemperatur der wärmste war
der hinter mir er war am nächsten an der
heizanlage
[Musik]
5 boiler bringen bis zu siebeneinhalb
millionen liter meerwasser auf
badetemperatur bevor es in die becken
fließt
bis zu 10.000 menschen haben ihr platz
hydro hat das bis dahin größte hallenbad
der welt gebaut
wann desto besser als das bad 1894
eröffnet wurde waren die leute sprachlos
angesichts der gigantischen pracht halle
yu sagte immer dass der komplette
stadtteil juni in das gebäude passen
würde
das war nicht nur ein schwimmbad sondern
auch eine art theater so wusste dass
nicht alle leute zum schwinden herkamen
manche wollten einfach nur zuschauen
also plante er sitzreihen ein und ist
den ganzen ballast fantasievoll
dekorieren er macht keine halben sachen
[Musik]
die anlage war wunderschön und genial
zugleich
denn die flut kam kann man könnte das
meerwasser die becken und beide floss es
wieder ab einen netto hat er im
schwimmbad gebaut dass ich zweimal am
tag selbst mit frischem wasser versorgte
die schwimmhalle am meer wird ein voller
erfolg aber warum ist sie heute
verfallen
dieses gebäude musste von anfang an viel
aushalten mit all den stürmen an der
küste
und auch wenn die menschen es damals
noch nicht wussten die gegend gehört zu
den gefährlichsten erdbebenregionen der
welt und 1906 erschüttert ein heftiges
erdbeben san francisco
drei viertel der stadt liegen in
trümmern
doch die superbikes überstehen die
katastrophe
wenn ihnen nicht mal ein erdbeben etwas
anhaben kann was dann
dieses gebäude hat ein erdbeben überlebt
und die wuchtige zeiten über viele
jahrzehnte sein ende wirkt wie eine
groteske laune des schicksals es ging in
flammen auf
1966 spricht in der nähe ein feuer aus
starke winde verwandeln den brand
schnell in ein inferno
innerhalb weniger stunden brennt das bad
bis auf die grundmauern ab
oft brechen gerade die dinge das genick
die man am wenigsten erwartet und hier
war feuer das aus für dieses meisterwerk
der baukunst
[Musik]
heute kümmert sich die
nationalparkverwaltung um die anlage des
udraw bäder haben kaum etwas von ihrer
faszination verloren
jemand hat mir mal gesagt san francisco
ist eine junge stadt wir haben nicht
viele ruinen aber das hier sind unsere
jeden tag kommen hunderte wenn nicht
sogar tausende menschen her um das
gelände zu erkunden
[Musik]
auf der insel tasmanien im äußersten
süden australiens liegt eine imposante
ansammlung alter gemäuer
[Musik]
man denkt sofort an einen ballast oder
ein herrenhaus aber es lohnt sich
genauer hinzuschauen
auf einer grünen halbinsel stößt man auf
eine ruine die wie ein mittelalterliches
kloster aussieht mit schlafsälen
werkstätten und einer kirche
die mischung ist irritierend jedes
gebäude hat eine andere form und größe
das ganze könnte eine fabrik gewesen
sein oder ein lager es hat aber auch
etwas düsteres als ensemble ergeben die
gebäude keinen sinn
hier kommt man sich vor wie am ende der
welt wer auch immer das gebaut hat
wollte wahrscheinlich dass die bewohner
zu niemandem kontakt haben
warum entstanden diese häuser an einem
so abgelegenen ort
hinter den ansehnlichen fassaden
verbirgt sich ein dunkles geheimnis
[Musik]
schon erstaunlich dass ein paar ruinen
ausreichen um eine idyllischen
landschaft den anstrich von tiefen
menschlichen leid zu verleihen
das war einer der meisten gefürchteten
orte australiens
da wollte niemand sein wer es doch tat
kam wahrscheinlich nie mehr zurück
jeder der den ort kannte dachte mit
grausen daran aber warum
[Musik]
der ursprung der anlage liegt rund
16.000 kilometer entfernt in
großbritannien
im achtzehnten jahrhundert führt die
britische krone eine neue strafe für
schwerverbrecher ein
verurteilte werden in die kolonien
verband
damals empfanden immer mehr leute die
strafen für kapitalverbrechen als zu
hart und unmenschlich
wiederholungstäter auf zu knüpfen hätte
man sie weit weg
ursprünglich deportierte man britische
gefangenen an die ostküste von
nordamerika sie landeten in
sträflingskolonie zum beispiel dort wo
heute der bundesstaat georgia
aber 1783 müssen sich die briten etwas
neues suchen
nach dem amerikanischen
unabhängigkeitskrieg war die britische
kolonialherrschaft dort geschichte also
konnte großbritannien keine
strafgefangenen mehr dorthin schicken
und die justiz musste sich etwas
einfallen lassen von da an wurden die
schlimmsten verbrecher nach down under
geschickt
1770 landet der britische entdecker
james cook in motten ebay und auf die
gegend new south wales
18 jahre später kommen hier die ersten
gefangenen transporter an
und an nachschub mangelt es nicht die
gesellschaftlichen umbrüche während der
industriellen revolution lassen die
kriminalitätsraten in die höhe schnellen
[Musik]
aus dem gesamten britischen empire
wurden mehr als 165.000 menschen nach
australien geschickt als wäre es ein
einziges großes gefängnis
innerhalb kurzer zeit entstehen überall
auf dem kontinent sträflingskolonie
die berüchtigste liegt in tasmanien bord
[Musik]
die anlage galt als ausbruchssicher das
meer war voller high es gab nur eine
schmale landbrücke zum festland
die wahl durch zäune wachen und
halbverhungerte wachende gesichert
die abgelegene halbinsel ist wie gemacht
für eine sträflingskolonie
9000 der gefährlichsten verbrecher
großbritanniens werden hier
untergebracht
aber war für zwei sorgen kriminelle
berüchtigt wie peace fm
wiederholungstäter sie sich einfach
nicht von der schiefen bahn abbringen
ließen und besonders schwere jungs die
die schrecklichsten verbrechen begangen
hatten
das ganze hatte auch einen
idealistischen hintergrund
die gefangenen sollten durch arbeit
wieder auf den rechten weg finden
im strafvollzug ist dass damals ein
völlig neuer ansatz und porta verdient
als riesiges versuchslabor
man setzte auf produktivität
die gefangenen sich nützlich machen
würden sie vielleicht einen neuen
lebenssinn spüren so die theorie aus dem
gefängnis wurde also im weitesten sinne
eine fabrik
potthoff er wird zum industrie knast in
dem kriminelle wie zwangsarbeiter
schuften als
holzfäller schiffsbauer oder müller
die bedingungen sind extrem hart vor
allem in der mühle
56 männer mussten das rund um die uhr
drehen um das korn zu malen
die gefangenen machten hier viele
tausend schritte am tag das war eine
unglaublich harte strafe
gleichzeitig hatte es einen
wirtschaftlichen nutzen denn das mehl
landete in den essent rationen der
gefangenen
in porta setzt man aber nicht nur auf
körperliche züchtigung
[Musik]
die insassen sind auch großen
psychischen druck ausgesetzt
hinter diesem neuen denkens stand vor
allem ein mann
er war überzeugt dass prügel und
peitschenhiebe kriminelles verhalten nur
förderten und dass man stattdessen einen
neuen umgang mit häftlingen finden
musste um sie zu resozialisieren
das klingt nach einer vergleichsweise
milden form des strafvollzugs
aber in der realität ist das neue system
genauso hart wie das alte vor allem in
diesem trakt am rand der anlage
hier sind die einzelzellen
da kamen die leute rein die zu hart
drauf waren um mit den anderen
gefangenen zu leben
investitions diese insassen wurden
ständig überwacht und saß hinter
meterdicken mauern in einzelhaft
sie mussten kapuzen tragen und durch
dann nicht mit anderen häftlingen reden
das grenzt an psychoterror sie saßen 23
stunden am tag in die isolationszelle
und mussten die ganze zeit schweigen
das hier ist eine so genannte strafzölle
dem isolations tag brachen die
gefangenen ohnehin schon 23 stunden am
tag eingeschlossen wer sich nicht
benehmen konnte landete für 48 stunden
am stück in so einer zelle getrennt von
den anderen insassen bei wasser und brot
es gab vielfach verstärkte kerker türen
und besonders dicke wände niemand konnte
die schreie hören die gefangenen wurden
einfach im dunkeln weggesperrt
schweigen und isolation sollen die
häftlinge dazu bringen über ihre
verbrechen nachzudenken
in der kirche sollten sie auf den
rechten weg finden ein nachvollziehbarer
gedanke aber die gefangenen sollten
dabei trotzdem isoliert bleiben
deswegen waren die kirchenbänke mit
kleinen kabinen versehen so konnten sie
zwar den fahrer sehen und hören aber
nicht ihre mitgefangenen
man kann sich kaum einen extremeren
angriff auf die eigene identität
vorstellen die männer dort müssen sich
mutterseelenallein geführt haben
was wurde aus den verurteilten die
import aber landeten
manche der gefangene überlebten die
torturen sie wurden handwerker aus
lienen als teil der kolonial bevölkerung
die weniger glücklichen landeten auf
einem friedhof der als insel der toten
bekannt war mindestens 1000 häftlinge
wurden hier beigesetzt die meisten in
namenlosen gräbern
in den 1800 50er jahren stellt
großbritannien die deportationen 1
1877 schließt die sträflingskolonie
kurz darauf mausert sich dort aber zu
einem besuchermagneten
sobald es geschlossen war kamen
schaulustige um zu sehen was die
verurteilten hier durchmachen mussten
und prinz philip
dort aber wird zu einem freilichtmuseum
und zu einer der wichtigsten
touristenattraktionen tasmaniens doch
das gehirn kehrt noch einmal zurück
[Musik]
die 1996 kam es hier zum größten
massaker der jüngeren australischen
geschichte
ein amokschütze erschießt von von 30
menschen das verbrechen erschüttert
australien bis ins mark innerhalb von
vier monaten reformiert die regierung
das waffenrecht voll und
halbautomatische waffen werden verboten
dann neue gesetze wurden erlassen die
regierung zog mehr als eine million
waffen ein und vernichtete sie
das massaker von porta hat australien
für immer verändert
[Musik]
heute zählt die anlage zu den
wichtigsten historischen orten des
landes
ihre mauern erzählen viele geschichten
in der oberpfalz unweit von nürnberg
liegen die überwucherten reste eines
gigantischen bauprojekts
[Musik]
wenn man durch diesen wald streift stößt
man plötzlich auf eine riesige schneise
dort sieht es aus als ob jemand fast
alle bäume abrasiert hätte
die stelle ist übersät mit steinblöcken
ich denke dass es die trümmer eines
hauses
sie erinnern fast an ruinen aus dem
alten rom griechenland oder kleinasien
die hass eines marktplatzes oder einer
akropolis
aber die dunkle geschichte dieses ortes
ist jünger sie beruht auf den plänen
eines brutalen regimes
sowie die blöcke angeordnet sind
gehörten sie offenbar zu einer größeren
struktur
lässt ihre position auf den
ursprünglichen zweck schließen die
verwitterten brücke sind über einen
steilen hang verteilt
wenn man darüber stolpert fragt man sich
was sie da am hügel zu suchen haben
es wirkt absurd warum sollte jemand so
viel zement mitten in den wald kippen
die spurensuche beginnt gut 30 kilometer
westlich in nürnberg eine stadt die im
nationalsozialismus unheilvollen ruhm
erlangt
1933 wird adolf hitler zum reichskanzler
ernannt innerhalb weniger monate baut er
die weimarer republik zur nazi-diktatur
um die mehrheit der deutschen steht
hinter dem selbst ernannten führer und
seiner partei der nsdap das land ächzt
seit jahren unter massenarbeitslosigkeit
durch öffentliche großaufträge wie den
bau der autobahnen und enorme
rüstungsausgaben kurbelt das ns-regime
die konjunktur an zum programm gehören
auch riesige propaganda veranstaltungen
nürnberg eine art hochburg der arischen
rasse
die massen inszenierungen verschaffen
den nationalsozialisten immer größeren
zulauf
propagandaminister joseph goebbels
hämmert den menschen die nazi ideologie
in den kopf und der plan geht auf
immer mehr deutsche lassen sich vom
rassenwahn und herren denken an stecken
nicht zuletzt wegen der eindrucksvollen
auftritte hitlers die reichsparteitage
sollen die einheit und stärke des
totalitären systems zeigen
als nationalsozialist hitler von der
deutschen geschichte fasziniert
in dem die reichsparteitage in nürnberg
ab und knüpfte an das heilige römische
reich
es werte 1000 jahre und begründete die
deutsche nation
nürnberg war die wichtigste bühne der
nazis
es war ihre zentrale kultstätte
sie wollten den deutschen und dem rest
der welt beweisen dass sie allein für
das ganze volk sprachen germans to the
movement jeder sollte sehen es gibt nur
einen führer und die menschen stehen
geschlossen hinter ihnen
um der ganzen welt zu zeigen dass sein
sogenanntes drittes reich ganz europa
für immer beherrschen wird plant hitler
ein gigantisches bauwerk
das deutsche stadion soll die
überlegenheit der nazis verkörpern
die ein bisschen geplant war eine
riesige tribüne mit platz für mehr als
400.000 menschen
es sollte so groß werden wie die vier
größten stadien der usa die es heute
gibt zusammengenommen auf
der ganzen welt hatte es noch nie so ein
großes stadion gegeben
[Musik]
das größenwahnsinnige projekt soll
hitlers leitender architekt und enger
vertrauter albert speer in die tat
umsetzen
so ein bauwerk ist ein echtes statement
power ein symbol der macht und autorität
aber was haben die betonreste im wald
damit zu tun
er wusste dass er vor dem eigentlichen
stadion erst einmal einen prototyp bauen
musste
als standort wählt er einen hang im
hirschbachtal
[Musik]
diese betonmauer hier gehört zum
fundament für die holzkonstruktion der
besucherring
man muss sich hier lange sitzreihen
vorstellen der hügel war damals komplett
abgeholzt
man hatte also frei sich nach unten
1937 beginnen die bauarbeiten auf dem
testgelände
damals stand hier ein realistisches eins
zu eins modell des größten stadions der
welt
es war wichtig ein paar dinge zu testen
bevor man mit dem eigentlichen bau los
lebte
unter anderem verschiedene sichtachsen
und neigungswinkel ausprobieren aber
das test stadion komplett zu bauen hätte
ewig gedauert wahnsinnig viel material
verbraucht und den eigentlichen stadion
dorf verzögert
also kann man auf die idee den hügel zu
nutzen denn er hatte genau den winkel
den auch die tribünen im stadion später
haben sollten
louis gergorin einem maßstabsgetreuen
modell kann man die gestaltung
überprüfen aber erst wenn man in
originalgröße baut bekommt man ein
gefühl für das stadion
eineinhalb jahre lang schuften hunderte
arbeiter auf dem testgelände
am ende stehen fünf tribünen ränge im
wald mit platz für zigtausende menschen
albert speer lädt hitler ein das teil
modell zu begutachten
kam später brauchte grünes licht von
hitler um weiterzumachen da am 21 märz
1938 kam der diktator vorbei sah sich um
und sagte auf neuen ordnung das machen
wir so
versteht es alle bereiche des
öffentlichen raums mit der
nazi-ideologie zu infizieren
das deutschen stadion in nürnberg sollte
die perfekte kulisse bieten um die
vermeintliche überlegenheit der
deutschen zur schau zu stellen
ideologie
arische rasse würde vor allem im kampf
gegen
die flair gegen die halbe welt krieg
führen will braucht eine nation von
kriegern
aber denn irgendwann alle nachbarländer
besiegt werden und die juden [ __ ]
und russen vernichtet
man dann noch kämpfen in diesem riesen
stadion wollten die nazis kampf spiele
austragen
unterhaltung für das volk unser auslese
der arischen rasse
in deutschen stadion sollte dem ideal
des kriegers gewürdigt werden
nur wenn man als junger mann kämpfen
kann man ein guter deutscher
davon zeugen heute nur noch ruinen
während des zweiten weltkriegs werden
die pläne für das mega stadion in
nürnberg auf eis gelegt und schließlich
aufgegeben
heute erobert sich der wald die beton
gespickte brachfläche langsam zurück
die hölzernen tribünen wurden nach dem
krieg für den wiederaufbau verwendet
[Musik]
mit dem holz wurde das nahe gelegene
dorf achte dass ein krieg zerstört
worden war wieder instand gesetzt da
nutzte es mehr als irgendwo im wald als
teil eines sinnlosen modells
[Musik]
einst waren sie symbole des
technologischen fortschritts
heute sind sie verlassen in diesen
verfallenen bauten sind die echos der
geschichte hörbar sie könnten von krieg
und terror vom erfindergeist und dem
streben nach fortschritt
[Musik]